Gianni here waiting for the racking to join me. You right?
Racking. A lot of smack being thrown around by Mr. Grich Ang wrestling is fake.
What are your thoughts on that?
Was it fake?
When I nabbed the gab out of that little Russia Hunter,
Mr. Michael rivalry, was it fake?
When I broke the spirit of that little Norwegian smut mannequin,
Mr. Crystal, was that fake? Rick?
Was it fake?
When I put the dirty you Nagi on little Bobby me
was that fake. Ricky,
the only thing not real here is you brother.
You little diet, denier, starch, addict, gout candidate.
I bet you can't even skate board.
Rick had some choice words for the fans of wrestling, calling them losers,
poor and even lowlifes. What are your thoughts on that rack? Can you think.
You're better than the regular folk? Rick?
You think you're better than wrestling fans than the regular people
run you out your little loose meat dinners? Well,
I got news for you.
What kind of news he is saying? Anyone can get it. Will you be the one? Right?
All you need to know,
Rick is that I'm ready because I'm going to give you the truth, baby.
And I'm going to give you the trauma name,
the time and the place and the place and the time.
Cause I got a clock and a globe and an ax to grind from
Alaska to Nebraska, from Maine to Fort Wayne.
It's your call? You Turkey, slicing monkey.
You won't know what happened when the rat King puts you in the mozzarella
splash. You'll be here in through your feet.
When I put you in the Swiss wheelchair, pick your poison.
You Walmart buddy.
Kack cause I'm going to hit her with the clutter.
I'm not hammer with dark glamour
and I'm going to show you how real.
There you have it. Folks.
The racking say hello to that little side piece of yours to mistake,
uh, the female, not the foul. She knows who I am.
He means business.